dicen que la belleza es solo superficial
pero sabías que la capa exterior de la
piel se compone de células completamente
muertas no tengo idea de cuál es la
belleza de un tejido muerto pero en este
vídeo intentaremos averiguarlo
hablaremos de las distintas capas de la
piel como podemos ver aquí la piel tiene
varias capas y hay tres conjuntos
distintos de capas que vamos a estudiar
la epidermis se compone de las primeras
cinco capas después tenemos la dermis
que la forman las siguientes dos y por
último tenemos el tejido subcutáneo o la
hipodermis en este vídeo empezaremos
hablando de la parte más superficial de
la piel
esa es la epidermis
estoy seguro que algunos de tus amigos
te ha dicho oye [ __ ] la epidermis y es
cierto ya que la epidermis es la capa
superior de la piel y comprende cinco
capas o como la llamaremos estratos cada
estrato tiene sus características
importantes empezaremos por la capa más
interna o más profunda de la epidermis
conocida como estrato basal o
germinativo o capa basal el estrato
basal se sitúa justo arriba de la dermis
es el lugar donde inicialmente generamos
queratinocitos vamos a dibujar varios de
ellos que era tim ositos el estrato
basal tiene varias capas de
queratinocitos como recordamos si todos
significa celular entonces que
significará queratina bueno viene de una
proteína o un filamento intermedio que
se llama sito queratina que es algo que
comenzamos a producir en el estrato
basal
a veces solo se llama queratina y ayuda
a darle resistencia a nuestra capa
externa hablaremos de esto en un minuto
en otros animales
la queratina es el ingrediente principal
de cosas como cuernos o incluso pezuñas
así que en definitiva es un material
resistente que protege nuestra piel
otra cosa importante que debemos saber
del estrato basal es que aquí tenemos
una división celular muy rápida porque
esta es la capa inferior de la epidermis
entonces las células se hacen aquí y
lentamente se mueven hacia arriba
también es importante saber que en el
estrato basal obtenemos el color de
nuestra piel hay componentes en este
estrato que determinan de qué color será
las células que confieren el color de la
piel que podemos ver aquí se llaman
melanocitos citó significa celular y me
la no indica la presencia de un pigmento
especial que se hace en estas células el
cual determina el color de nuestra piel
este pigmento se llama melanina lo
interesante de estas células es que no
es el número de melanocitos lo que
determina qué tan oscura es nuestra piel
de hecho las personas con piel de color
obscuro y piel de color claro
en el mismo número de melanocitos lo que
determina el color de tu piel es la
cantidad de melanina que tienes la gente
con piel obscura tiene más bella' ni na
bien es momento de movernos a nuestra
siguiente capa podemos ver que los
queratinocitos subieron también y se
empieza a notar un poco de la sit o
queratina que se ha producido y una de
las peculiaridades de esta siguiente
capa es que tenemos esta pequeña
conexión que se empezará a generar entre
los queratinocitos esta conexión se
conoce como desmo soma y está
involucrada en lo que le da nombre a
esta capa la capa que está encima del
estrato basal se conoce como estrato
espinoso y la razón por la cual se llama
así es la de smos soma cuando vemos a
través de un microscopio esta capa de la
piel con muy poca humedad o agua en las
células tendremos estas células secas
parecidas a unas estrellas o a células
espinosas con formas muy puntiagudas y
son puntiagudas porque siguen conectadas
por esta de smos o mã pero han perdido
su humedad esta es la razón por la que a
veces estas capas se ven
citas y espinosas debido a que perdieron
agua
de esta forma recordamos nombre estrato
espinoso otra célula que también habita
en esta capa es una célula inmunológica
que busca cuerpos extraños o patógenos o
cosas que puedan ser nocivas para tu
cuerpo como bacterias u hongos y se los
come estas se llaman células de
langerhans y como podemos adivinar son
partes de nuestro sistema inmunitario
pasan el rato aquí pero también pueden
viajar hacia las otras capas hablaremos
con mayor profundidad de estas células
en nuestros vídeos del sistema
inmunitario vayamos a nuestra siguiente
capa
esta capa más superficial se llama
estrato gránulos o lo que significa que
estamos en la capa gránulos a la razón
por la que le llamamos así es que los
queratinocitos que están aquí unidos por
las demos o más de las que hemos hablado
en la capa espinosa tienen una cantidad
tremenda de gránulos estos gránulos son
muy aparentes cuando los observamos bajo
un microscopio estos gránulos se llaman
gránulos de que era tobalina y
seguramente te estás preguntando si se
produce mucha más queratina en esta capa
bueno si se produce queratina pero estos
gránulos en realidad lo que almacenan no
es queratina osito queratina de la que
hablamos anteriormente ellos tienen un
montón de otras proteínas que nos ayudan
a manejar la queratina los gránulos de
queratina
a estas proteínas para manejar la
queratina ya que mueven las citó
queratina alrededor de la célula otra
cosa importante que hace el extracto
granuloso es que libera cuerpos
laminares y estos cuerpos laminares
contienen un montón de lípidos que al
unirse forman una capa lipídica firme
que se sitúa en la parte superior de
nuestra piel esta capa lipídica es
impermeable lo que le da a la piel la
capacidad de impermeabilidad que la
protege de patógenos foráneos que
quieran venir a invadir las
profundidades de la piel y llegar a la
sangre
bien la siguiente capa de la que
hablaremos es el estrato lucido esta es
nuestra capa lúcida o capa clara la
forma de pensar en ella es que en el
estrato gránulos o los queratinocitos
han trabajado tan duro para hacer estos
gránulos the creator yalina y liberar
estos cuerpos laminares que mueren al
llegar al extracto lúcido estas células
que están aquí éstos queratinocitos
están muertos son queratinocitos zombies
y así se ven en el microscopio ya que
han perdido su núcleo y otros órganos
que les daban el color que anteriormente
veíamos en las capas más vivas como
resultado esta capa no tendrá los
gránulos ni el núcleo ni los organelos
que vimos antes y por ende será más
clara o más transparente que las
anteriores así que es importante que
escribamos que en la capa lúcida
hemos perdido el núcleo
y los organelos que le daban color a la
célula cuando la veíamos bajo un
microscopio
y esta tendencia continúa cuando nos
movemos a la última capa este es el
estrato córneo la capa más externa de
toda nuestra piel podemos pensar en ella
como la capa forense y como sabes a los
cuerpos les hace una autopsia el médico
forense así que esta también es una capa
de piel muerta pero una de las
características que tenemos en el
estrato córneo es que tenemos capas
apiladas de queratinocitos muertos y
podemos tener de 15 a 20 capas apiladas
de estas células epiteliales delgadas
simples y escamosas vamos a escribirlo
podemos tener de 15 a 20 capas de
queratinocitos muertos ya que recordemos
murieron en la capa lúcida y como
estamos en la última capa observaremos
que estas células van a mudar de manera
aleatoria y constante
es decir se van a ir o se van a caer lo
que hace que nuevos queratinocitos o
nuevas células empiezan su camino hasta
la parte superior de la piel otra cosa
interesante de esta capa es que los
reptiles y lo escribiremos en verde como
reptiles los reptiles mudan esta capa de
piel en una sola pieza es por ello que
vemos que la serpiente deja su piel como
una cobertura única e intacta es decir
mudan por completo su estrato córneo es
muy interesante y también un poco
desagradable muy bien aquí tenemos las
cinco capas de la epidermis las dos
capas más externas están hechas de
células muertas mientras que las tres de
abajo o las tres más profundas de la
epidermis están formadas por células
vivas y si nos movemos aún más abajo y
empezamos a hablar de la dermis sus
células también están vivas y además
tienen vasos sanguíneos para nutrir las
puedes observar que no hay vasos
sanguíneos
la parte de la epidermis porque los
nutrientes y el oxígeno vienen desde
abajo y hacen su recorrido hasta arriba